[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
always a long shot but very much in the
balance
that's nicolas sturgeon's assessment of
winning a majority in the scottish
parliament with counting set to continue
today in constituencies and regions
across scotland
but even if the snp falls short of the
65 hollywood seats needed for an
outright victory
miss sturgeon is on a constitutional
collision course with boris johnson
who's told the daily telegraph a second
independence referendum would be
irresponsible well this is the current
state of the parties in scotland the s p
hold a commanding lead with 39 seats in
parliament
a gain of three so far the liberal
democrats have four seats
the conservatives have three and labour
two our political correspondent joe pike
reports
from glasgow yesterday in glasgow nicola
sturgeon was victorious in her south
side seat
but will that winning streak continue
today the path to an all-important snp
majority
is now looking tough if people of
scotland
vote for a pro-independence referendum
majority in the scottish parliament
whether that's an snp majority which is
very much in the balance and you know
has always been a long shot or
an snp green majority then that has to
be respected
and that's a basic principle of
democracy
oh yeah scottish labour have held on to
two key marginals
but the snp were desperate to win ten
weeks ago people were predicting i was
at 14
in the polls i think when i took over
the job people can see
the energy and the enthusiasm we brought
to the campaign over the last 10 weeks i
think we have got some hope and optimism
elsewhere boris johnson has secured a
big by-election win in hartlepool
ben halchen the conservative party
candidate
is duly elected as mayor for the tease
valley
combined authority and ben houchen
turned the once marginal tease valley
marity
into a tory stronghold with a majority
of 76
000. the conservatives made yet more
progress in labour territory winning
northumberland in the northeast
dudley redditch and nuneaton in the
midlands
there was better news for labour in
wales where so far the party have held
their ground
and first minister mark drakeford
increases majority by more than ten
thousand votes today we'll get the rest
of the welsh results and find out who
will be the mayors of london
the west midlands and greater manchester
counting continues for a second day
across scotland including the
distribution of 56
regional seats nicola sturgeon is as
expected on course to win an historic
fourth term for the smp if she stays in
her job until next summer
she will be scotland's longest serving
first minister
but we still don't know whether she will
win the majority she argues
will give her a mandate for a second
independence referendum
the magic number nicola sturgeon needs
is 65.
if he doesn't get there party pressure
for a more radical independent strategy
may
be on the horizon joe pike sky news
glasgow
well a challenging election so far for
labour but the party has had some
success in wales
mark drakeford extended his own majority
in cardiff west by more than 10 000
votes and said his party
has exceeded expectations eight regional
seats will announce results today
but labour is so far on 30 seats one
short
of a senate majority the welsh
conservatives have 12
seats and did manage to take veil of
fluid from labor
flag camry have nine seats while the
liberal democrats have won
dan whitehead reports from cardiff
they were braced for a bumpy ride but
welsh labour are breathing a sigh of
relief
the conservatives had hoped to shake up
seats like the veil of glamorgan
but in the end voters here in barrie
stuck with labour
through the pander about pandemic i
think mark rakeford's done very well
actually
um i think he's been a safe sure pair of
hands
i think mark drave would have done very
well when you think now they're
vaccinating
18 year olds yeah i think they've done
very well
much better than what they have in
england
results are still coming in but the red
wall in north wales
held with labour keeping hold of wrexham
allen and d-side and clewwood south
first minister mark drakeford kept his
seat as did health minister vaughan
gething
who said the party can't be complacent
we need to be prepared to listen and to
learn from whatever the results are good
bad or indifferent because otherwise we
will lose touch with our people during
this election though as i say i'm proud
of the positive way we've campaigned
it is going to be some days before we
know the exact makeup of the new welsh
parliament but what is clear
is that labour has managed to hold most
of its seats
and continue its dominance after more
than two decades
the valley town of murtha tidville
continues to be a labor stronghold
it bore the brunt of covid19 putting
devolved health
firmly in voters minds they've done a
good job with about you know
this way yes because they aren't rushed
to get their you know
pubs open and all this and that jake put
down
you know he's had to do what he had to
do but i think they could have done a
bit better
quicker quicker the tories did win
two new seats but so far the party and
plyd kumri
have failed to disrupt labour's reign
dan whitehead sky news in cardiff
meanwhile in the english council
elections results have so far
made positive reading for the tories
they've made a net gain of six
authorities
while labor has made a net loss of four
the environment secretary george eustis
joins us now good morning to you
um after the the success of hartley paul
um
the the government and various other uh
conservative
gains commentators are saying that now
there has been a political shift
in the the landscape to the the
conservative party
is that your reading of the situation
well these are a very very good set of
results for us i mean it's been the case
now for some time that
conservative councils have a reputation
for delivering services well and
delivering them in a
cost-effective way so we've made further
gains in those local authorities but the
big breakthrough
i think in in hartlepool and in the tees
valley
mayoral election uh these are these are
great results for us and i think really
what it shows is
some of those areas feel that the labour
party
has represented them for a long time no
longer really is in tune with their
priorities i think that the
decision to leave the eu which parts of
the country like that
wanted to see done and wanted that
result respected i think that probably
uh changed things but also they're
seeing a conservative party that's
really in touch
with their priorities let's talk about
um scotland
uh where do you stand on the possibility
of a second referendum still results are
coming in but but what is the
position of the government on that well
look
we had a referendum in scotland just
about five years ago there was a result
there
um i just think as we try to come out of
this pandemic
and as we focus on the economic recovery
as we come out of it
it really isn't the time to do
constitutional tinkering and
and have you know another divisive
referendum i just don't think
uh that is what people want and the
government's very clear that we've had a
referendum
and now is not the time to have another
one but if the snp win
a majority would you grant them
that uh privilege of holding another
referendum well look it's something
that the uk parliament is the only
anyone that can actually
grant a referendum that's always been
the case
we've had one recently so they've had
their referendum it was
described as a once in a generation
referendum
we really don't think there's a case for
another one particularly as we try to
come out of this
pandemic and focus on the issue of
getting
economic recovery going and getting back
in the saddle as a country
as we come out of this uh difficult
pandemic the
prime minister has said been quoted i
think in the telegraph today saying it
would be irresponsible
but but would the the government be
prepared to go to court to actually
block it would with the government go
that far well look i'm not going to sort
of get into these sort of hypothetical
questions we still don't have
the full results in scotland i know
there's speculation about what might
happen
the government's got a very clear
position that we just don't think now's
the time
for another referendum we've had one
recently we've got more important things
that we should all be focusing on
and that's our position you say it's
hypothetical but but what is the overall
plan
for the union will you just uh keep
saying no or is there something else
that is in
the the pipeline to offer well look i
think it's really important
uh that that we start that the family of
nations that make up the uk which is the
most
successful union in history and that we
start to really work out
areas where we can work together so
there's a lot of work going into
policy coordination particularly in
those policy areas that
used to be run by the european union
where we've regained control
making sure that we've got uk wide
coordination
we've had the uk internal markets act
which ensures that there's
unfettered access around the uk internal
market and which creates you know the
ability for uk government to
deliver and spend on people's priorities
right through
our united kingdom so that we can help
get some cohesion to the uk
which has got it's the most successful
union in history and um
this it's something that we should
really nurture it's a very precious
thing for us
uh following on from the the success in
in the local elections uh some of the
papers today
uh predicting that boris johnson could
be in power for 10 years in fact he
could
exceed the duration of margaret thatcher
is that something that you predict that
that you can see happening
well i don't think you can ever uh
predict uh elections that far ahead and
it's certainly
no complacency at all on our part
there's a very good
set of uh elections for us we've made
breakthroughs in areas where we've not
represented before
you know but with that comes a really
important responsibility for us
as conservatives which we recognize and
that is not to
let people down we've got to deliver for
those areas that have put their faith
and their confidence in us
that's what we're going to be focusing
on not speculating about what might be
happening in 10 years time
just want to quickly talk about the
travel list the the traffic light system
and the
countries that have been released to be
on the green list some of them
aren't even holiday destinations at all
south georgia and south sandwich islands
uh on the green list um the only things
that are there
uh are penguins what's the point of
actually including countries like that
and actually
some countries are not receiving us even
though they're on
our green list well look this is a
cautious start to trying to loosen up
travel we've been
cautious about loosening the
restrictions throughout grant shaps has
made clear that we'll review these
lists every three weeks this is the
initial
list i think it does include countries
um like for instance portugal and israel
and australia and new zealand
i know it's a it's a modest first step
others will remain either on the amber
list well i need to quarantine at home
or indeed on the red list but it will be
reviewed again in three weeks time and
as the situation changes and improves
more countries will be added to that
green list turkey's on the the red list
due to to host the
champions league final um should we be
pushing more to have a venue in in the
uk for that competition
i think aston villa have offered up
their ground yes i understand that
um discussions with uefa are taking
place
and i think um i'm sure that oliver
dowden at dcms will
will be engaged in this but i think it's
the case that uh you know the uk is
willing to
to offer to host uh it you know here
in the uk if that makes things easier
but obviously it would be a decision for
for uefa on that particular match the
difficulty is we've had to take a
decision
on turkey based on the evidence we do so
on objective criteria
and that's why sadly we've had to put
turkey on the red list
george just thank you very much for
speaking to us this morning
let's take a look at the front pages of
the morning's newspapers for you now
the day boris blew up labor that's the
daily mail's assessment of the election
results
the eye keeps things brief labor in
turmoil they say
the guardian has a similar headline
the financial times credits the
conservative success to what they call
johnson's vaccine bounce
but the express has its own theory about
about saying it's down
to brexit the times thinks the results
could keep
boris johnson in number 10 for a decade
the telegraph leads with the prime
minister ruling out another independence
referendum in scotland
and the sheffield star is one of the
many local papers across the country
focusing on the elections
in their case the shift of the city's
council from labour to no
overall control in other news the daily
star
references the fast show while covering
the announcement
of the list of countries where britons
will soon be allowed to go on holiday
and the sun features a story involving
chef jamie oliver who turned detective
to track down a stolen tractor
some of the other main stories for you
now and kent police have identified a
man
whose picture was shared as part of an
investigation
into the murder of pcso julia james the
force
says they're no longer seeking
information about the individual in the
photo but are still keen to hear from
anyone
who may have information relevant to the
case
at least 178 palestinians and six
israeli officers have reportedly been
injured at the al-aqsa mosque and around
east jerusalem
as tensions continued to soar over the
threatened eviction of palestinians
in the sheikh jarrah neighborhood police
in riot gear fired rubber bullets and
stun grenades at crowds who threw
objects at them
yesterday thousands of worshippers
marked the final friday of ramadan
at the holy site with many staying on to
protest
israel's supreme court is due to hold a
hearing on the sheikh jarrah evictions
on monday
the united nations has called on israel
to immediately halt all forced evictions
saying any implementation would violate
israel's obligations
under international law
more than a million children will be
given access to mental health support as
the nhs
expands its services in a bid to help
people cope with disruption
from the pandemic children experiencing
anxiety and depression will be offered
support in a bid to prevent problems
escalating into serious mental health
issues
that continue into adulthood nhs england
says around 400 mental health
support teams will work across three
thousand schools
in england
the government has confirmed foreign
travel for holidays can resume in just
over
two weeks on may the 17th an updated
traffic light system
sees 12 countries including australia
and portugal on the green list
but other popular destinations such as
france and spain have failed to make the
cut
and the concessions to travel come with
several conditions
as our business correspondent paul kelso
reports
no cues no kids and almost no passengers
gatwick's departure halls have been
empty for months but that's about to
change
with a new traffic light system
replacing the blanket travel
ban 12 countries including portugal
israel
australia and the falkland islands are
on the green list
that will not require travelers to
quarantine on return
though not all currently admit britain's
major destinations france spain and
greece are on the amber list
subject to 10 days home quarantine while
turkey
has been added to the red list of
countries requiring mandatory hotel
quarantine
part of what the transport secretary
defended as a deliberately cautious
approach
a fortnight in the falklands isn't most
people's idea
of a summer holiday is it realistic to
think that this year we will see the
return
of mass travel look this is not a list
generated and created um to
if you like um think about where people
want to lie on beaches and then twist
the science
uh to fit it that would be completely
wrong it would go against
everything that we have said steve is
among thousands disappointed by the news
his annual lads holiday to benidorm was
postponed last year
and needs due to pay the balance on
monday but he'll lose the lot
if spain is still on the amber list come
june
completely gutted i understand that we
have to be cautious
but it's it could have made it a lot
fairer
and the way that traffic light system
works to me
it's only the wealthy or people that own
their companies
that are going to go another on our
holiday
travelers can't come soon enough for
destinations that thrive on british
visitors
and the news at least represents a
little ray of sunshine for portugal
if we back to 2019
we are talking about the uk
being responsible for
almost 6 million room night stays
in our hotels which represents about
40 percent of our overall international
touristic demands turkey's red list
status means 8 000 fans of manchester
city and chelsea
may not be able to make the champions
league final currently scheduled for
istanbul
for the rest of us any foreign holiday
this summer
might be considered a result paul kelso
sky news at gatwick
let's take a look now the latest
coronavirus figures and they've been
2490 new cases of coronavirus in the
most recent 24-hour period
15 more deaths have been reported which
means the total number of people who
died within 28 days of a positive test
now stands at 127
598. another 135
470 people have received their first
vaccination
470 0001
have received their second that means
more than 51.83 million jabs in total
have now been given out across the uk
time now for a look at the weather with
isabelle and i've had a quick
glimpse outside it's wet
yeah and as the director just said that
swirly thing
behind me is the reason low pressure
it's driving the fronts in and yes it's
wet i mean the gardens need more rain
that's good yeah and it's looking a bit
warmer as well which is such a nice
treat because it's been well we had such
a cold april frostiest on record
and so far this month has been pretty
chilly but it will feel different today
so let's take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
so behind me then the atlantic
depression or area of low pressure
that's driving these fronts northwards
across us and as julian said it is
raining outside and for all of us today
a spell of wet weather
but for some as the rain clears later
it'll turn a little bit brighter and you
will feel the effects of this southerly
wind the warmth that's coming in behind
this rain band
so across southern ireland then central
parts of ireland temperatures picking up
to around about
17 degrees this afternoon a few showers
possible
and also southeast england east anglia
up to about 17 to 19 celsius
this afternoon so very different
hopefully some sunshine breaking through
there might be a little bit of late
sunshine too across southern scotland
and northern england but otherwise
the rest of scotland stays wet and wales
into the west midlands
and much of western england stays pretty
wet as well the highest rainfall totals
i should think in a 24-hour period will
be
across the brecon beacons as we head
through this evening tonight we're quite
mild tonight
still the remnants of our rain across
central parks gradually breaking up
tomorrow
and then tomorrow it's a day of sunshine
and showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
welcome back to sky news breakfast now
as results continue to come in from
elections around the uk
jane secker is here for a look at the
latest numbers taken away
yeah thanks very much jillian well we've
seen overnight
uh these are the main pictures from the
three countries across
the uk that had the elections yesterday
and it's an interesting picture isn't it
in each of them the leader that was seen
to handle the pandemic well is the one
whose party has seen to do well
the conservatives of course in england
the snp
in scotland and in wales the labour
party let's just quickly break down
uh some of those uh constituencies in
england
very different picture from this time
yesterday morning lots of blue on the
map
but with still lots of results still to
declare
remember of course that a lot of those
blue seats that the conservative party
has taken
are very very key ones and they are
seats that they would never have taken
in the past like a lot of those in the
midlands
and when we look at the number of seats
overall yes there are losses for the
conservatives yes there are losses for
the labour party
but by and large it's the conservatives
that have made massive gains
the labour party that has lost a huge
number of seats the greens too wants to
keep an eye on they've done very well
dreadful night for the lib dems uh not a
lot of attention on them really but they
have not done
especially well at all a lot of
attention's been focused on hartlepool
that was the by-election yesterday and
this is a really interesting
uh piece of graphics this shows um
the numbers of people that have voted
uh four in by-elections since back 1945
since just after the second world war
now until hartlepool every parliament
since the second world war
the vote share of the incumbent party
has gone down so that really shows you
how significant what happened in
parliament was
in hartlepool was yesterday uh quick
look at scotland
uh that's going to be interesting today
we're going to get more results today
snp have done well overnight they took
air they took
east slovean they took edinburgh central
what's going to happen at this
constituency aberdeenship west that's
the key one keep an eye on that if they
do well there
it could really signal a very good day
for nicola sturgeon
jane thank you well joining me now is
the shadow home secretary nick
thomas uh simmons good morning to you
first of all
what what happened in hartlepool in your
estimation
well good morning and lovely to join you
i knocked doors
in hartley pool i also knock doors right
across
wales and here in wales we obviously did
extremely well in my own constituency
we won more votes than ever before in
a devolved election now what i was
looking towards in hartlepool in
contrast
to here what i saw in hartlepool were
people who
didn't believe the labour party stood
for them that they felt the labour party
had drifted away from them and didn't
have the answers to their everyday
concerns whereas here in wales that was
very different
here in wales people admired that the
leadership through the pandemic of mark
drakeford
and also identified strongly with labor
and labor having
the solutions for the future and i think
there is a lesson for us
there in terms of what we've done in
wales what we've achieved in wales
speaking in every single community
that we really do now need to transfer
to england and those parts of england
like hartlepool
where we desperately need to do a great
deal better so so exactly what what is
the
the first minister getting right that
seemingly secure stamina
is getting so wrong it's not a question
of kiyosama getting things wrong we have
a situation
here in wales where we got a developed
policy agenda
and a party that for where there is no
no-go area
across wales and that's of course a
great thing for us and something to
learn from
in terms of ikea here at westminster has
had the last year
in the pandemic he's acted in the
national
interest that's why we've backed for
example things like the furlough scheme
that's why we've backed the public
health messaging
and it was in the national interest to
do that
kia has also made a start on changing
the party but what kia now
will do is go even faster with that
change
and what i'm looking to see over the
next 12 months as we move out of the
pandemic
is kia able now to actually connect with
the public he has not
actually given a speech to a room of
people
as leader of the labour party and the
kiostama that i know
is driven by tackling injustice by
tackling inequality those are the
qualities that led
me to back him to be the leader of the
labour party
you seem to be saying that he didn't get
anything wrong
well look we we've cle we've clearly got
things severely wrong in hartlepool
that's why
we lost to the extent we did but it is
also the case
that having lost four general elections
in a row
it was never going to be turned around
in 12 months
i recognize absolutely that we have a
great
deal to do but my point is this the kia
has started
that work has laid courageously on
things like
tackling anti-semitism within the labour
party he started
to create that change within the labour
party and that's now what we've got to
develop
and as we move out of the pandemic the
public will have that chance to see the
kia stammer that i know
that will be out tackling inequality at
the forefront of his mission in politics
and that is something of course we've
not been able to do to the same extent
during the pandemic
but of course kia can now do going
forward and accelerate the process of
change
that he's put in place polling yesterday
by jail
partners uh showed that the top reason
given for for people not voting
for labour was sakira stama's leadership
described as uninspiring and soft uh
isn't that the the real issue that the
top team has has just been too
cautious no when i i read that
uh that you're referring to and that was
i think it was about 14
of people said that but in in any event
the point is that we have to have
had the you know the leadership that
we've had during the pandemic i think
that was very important i think kia got
that judgment
absolutely right it had to be
constructive opposition i think
the public rightly expected that obvious
and that's what we should have done
our priority was to save lives during
the pandemic of course we've called out
the government
when they've got things wrong at
westminster but at the same time we
provided that constructive opposition
now as we move into the next phase we're
certainly not out of the woods yet with
the pandemic by the way
but as we do that's when now kia can
set out his real passion to change our
country to make sure that we don't go
back
to the failed unequal insecure economic
model of the past
and that's what i i know kia will be
doing in in the months and years
ahead but that is not to criticize the
approach he's taken during the pandemic
because i think it was absolutely the
correct thing to do
we've seen brexit leading areas uh
moving towards the the conservatives is
the real issue here that
sakia starmer um has been known in the
past
as a remainer the wrong the wrong person
in in this role
no i i don't i don't think that at all
and i
knocked a number of doors in hartley
pool and people didn't raise the
the issue of brexit it was the issue of
the future
the jobs of the future the good schools
for their children
a health service that they can rely on
these are the kind of issues that are
being raised to me
on the streets of hartlepool and i know
that kia has a vision for those things
that the public services that we went
into the pandemic had been undermined by
the conservatives over the previous 10
years
that he is passionate about a
world-class education for
every child to tackle the inequality in
our society so i know that what we will
now
do of course in the months and years
ahead is to show if you like to put the
meat on the bones of that to set out the
policies to review
the policies that we have and to have
those policies
that do reflect post-pandemic
britain that can put before the election
the next general election
shadow home secretary thank you thank
you
tom now for a look at the weather with
isabel
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather sponsored by qatar airways
we've got rain for today it's already
raining heavily across many central and
southern parts this morning with the
rain pushing right up into the north
giving a cold day there
but elsewhere as the winds turn
southerly well with a bit of an
improvement through the course of the
day i think it'll actually feel quite
nice so it starts off wet
miserable conditions out there but i
think quite possible that
across ireland through the afternoon
temperatures could reach around 17
degrees
southeast and past the country also up
to about 17 to 19
with maybe a little bit of late sunshine
as well but elsewhere it's a pretty wet
picture
the rain slowest to clear northern
scotland and also dragging its heels
across wales and western parts of
england and for example south wales
could be in for
a significant soaking tomorrow that rain
breaks up though
and it'll be brighter again with
scattered showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
back with us now to take us through the
newspapers of the journalist and
broadcaster fedexa and former government
special adviser mo hussein welcome back
to you both
starting with you first of all mo and
the front page of
the mail the day boris blew up labour
and there's someone looking over his
shoulder in that photo
uh yes indeed i mean this process did
start
a few years ago where we saw labor uh
see its worst electoral defeat in 85
years
back in 2019 and yesterday was really
a chance to see has anything changed has
any progress been made
under kierstrama the labor to try and
reconnect with its heartlands
that the conservatives took from them
and it seems that the answer is no
uh not just in hartlepool but also in
many local councils
that labor have now lost or seen their
majorities uh certainly slashed
it's quite unusual for governments to
win by elections as well particularly 11
years in
so i think this is a really fundamental
resetting of our
political system and yes there will be
an impact around the vaccine bounds and
the idea of
unlocking the country and going back to
a sense of normality
but it seems to me what has really
struck a chord is this
idea the government has spoken about a
lot which is
leveling up the country which is about
jobs and investment
and now the government has to deliver on
this you know these people
who have voted conservative probably
have never voted conservative before
and they are expecting to see uh the
government come
good on the things that they said they
would deliver so over the next few years
i think we will see
a lot more focus on these parts of the
country and a lot more money
going into them yes and staying with
that thought of the the bounce many um
pointing towards what they're describing
is that the vaccine bouncing bedisha
you've had look
at the eye the story there the under 40s
will now be offered an alternative
to the astrazeneca jab
yes there are lots of headlines about
this and it seems to imply that under
40s
are going to be given some sort of
choice of an array of drugs but in fact
it's uh it's very telling that after a
little bit of diplomatic cautious
silence government advisers
are actually pushing forward the idea of
those other two vaccines the moderna
and the fisa vaccines after the
astrazeneca vaccine was found
in a very small number of cases so one
in a hundred thousand
but there have been some fatalities to
have a link i don't want to say cause to
have a link to very rare
blood clots and in the u.s the johnson
and johnson vaccine
has found similar results because they
use the same
biotechnology it's interesting to me
because for a long time the
success story around the uk's vaccine
rollout was all about astrazeneca
and i do think the government advisers
staged stone for a little while because
they thought
hang on maybe this is just a case of
normal results
because no vaccine is 100 safe and
secure
normal results somehow being skewed or
somehow this vaccine being briefed
against so
there's a sense of the diplomacy the
geopolitics
behind the so-called uk vaccine story
but it's very significant for me at
least that the government advisors have
put forward a clear statement
saying that if possible while the
vaccine rollout is successful while case
numbers remain
low and the choice is possible in order
to
keep uptake going they should get a
different one
yeah worrying though for those uh under
the age of 40 who've already had the
first
jab of astrazeneca uh and we've been
told that
you can't mix vaccines um it's already
been done so yes you can sympathize with
them
to the telegraph mo uh what's this about
uh weekly
food recycling could be delayed by up to
eight years
yeah yes indeed so this was something
that we thought would come in by 2023
we're now hearing it could be
delayed by quite a a number of years
eight years in fact
and this will be disappointing and
surprising to a lot of people
uh because we're seeing a really big
push on the green agenda
on the environmental agenda coming from
very top of government
and it feels like uh especially in the
year that the uk is hosting the climate
change talks as well
and the fact that we want to show some
kind of leadership on this that we
should really be getting
our own housing order and being able to
take forward some of these
measures in this case food recycling and
other kinds of recycling
it feels like cost has become an issue
and maybe just the logistics of doing
this
but actually for us to even meet any of
our net zero targets and other targets
uh in terms of greenhouse gases we will
have to make
quite big changes to our everyday lives
uh so
if if this can't be done then i just
worry about
the rest of it as well in terms of
actually achieving
uh those targets and people really
understanding the role that they
as a society overall will have to play
yeah so
getting these things down so instead of
leaving food to rot
in landfill which emits methane
we're going to have it rotting at home
correct yeah exactly and potentially for
a lot longer than
a week as well so it just it just feels
like it's not connected to what we are
told
the why the strategy is meant to be
and um there's other things as well
around
exporting plastic that has not stopped
happening as well
so we have the narrative we have the
high level ambition but what we really
need to see is action
on the ground to piece all of this
together to take this agenda forward and
make
the change that the planet definitely
needs to see yes the reality very
different to the ambition there to the
sun
bedisha and the london merrell uh
contest
a little closer one thing than than
sadiq khan would have
wished for yes exactly i think that
everyone had assumed that in these uh
these mayoral elections of which the
results should be coming in
tonight or if covert protocols have
delayed the count
may be early tomorrow morning so it
would have should have could have been a
landslide for sadiq
khan and sean bailey the tory candidate
was seen as being really quite far
behind almost like
a sort of maverick candidate in actual
fact uh yes uh sadiq khan is doing great
but he's
only 25 000 overnight counted votes
ahead of sean
bailey bailey has done well in
traditional london suburbs and districts
including
bexley and bromley neither of them have
got the requisite 50
of votes that most voters would put
forward on their first preference
and so this second preference rollout
could go either way
either traditionally green and lib dam
voters
are going to think okay you know it's
really it's between khan and bailey so i
am going to be tactical
and vote for sadiq khan or they're going
to say
or they would have said when they were
doing it
it's more tricky than i initially
thought i'm going to vote with my heart
and actually give my green-hearted vote
to the green candidate in which case
sadiq khan is going to be listening to
all of his advisers today and early
tomorrow
seeing just how close he gets